so
[Applause]
happy week 12 everybody and welcome to
the br betting squad ride presented by
draftkings live in the bleacher report
app i hope you all had a great
thanksgiving and i hope you all followed
greg and i's parlay because we cashed
with the bills mafia on thursday night
greg feeling good feeling good i'm
connor rogers
alongside it's basically his time of the
year the holiday season the giving
season greg ivory greg how we feeling
today
connor feeling very generous phil and
generous it's not december it's still
november but we're still giving away
hoodies i'm actually in the comments
right now for the people that's new to
the show if you guys don't know now you
know this right here is the andy dandy
ipad this is how you get your hoodies
this is how you get jerseys it's how you
probably can get some money i don't know
but this is how you get tapped in i'm in
the comments right now connor i see uh
i see
goat garden says michael pittman equals
go shout out to you go garden i got
lonnie hoffman says raiders are gonna
kill it uh he's
yeah shout out to you ronnie lonnie you
are walking away with a hoodie connor
let's get this thing
going yeah let's get it rolling you know
the drill by now this is the show where
we bet anytime touchdown scores we are
looking for the lock of the week of
who's getting in the end zone we asked
you in the app we asked you on social
who's it going to be and these are your
top picks of the week jonathan taylor at
the top no surprise he scores literally
every week nashie harris and debo samuel
right behind him they've both been
fantasy superstars mike evans looking to
get it done against the colts kyle pitts
got that light match up against
jacksonville maybe the atlanta offense
gets on track jalen hurts against the
giants jalen hurts has been one of the
best players in fantasy all around and
then dk metcalf and odell beckham jr
coming in at plus
225. so interesting board today some new
names and as always plenty to give away
greg i know you got the hoodies but what
else you got in store for everyone yes
connor i'm not only giving away hoodies
i'm giving away two not one but two nfl
jerseys one to the winning lock legend
and one to a lucky commenter like
yourself
so get in the comments and do what you
guys do
fill them up i need i need emojis
i need uh
gifts i need sunsets i need connor is
the best i need hashtag winners only
please i need whatever you guys think of
fill those comments up but most
importantly connor
most importantly
we need winners
only
please we need winners only please so
make sure y'all filling those comments
up with some winners that's right and we
have four legendary picks to show you we
need one of these to be a winner and
it's gonna be our squad ride leader they
get the title
they get the nfl jersey gift card and
then we're gonna boost those odds we're
gonna trail it and we're gonna make some
money let's get this show on the road
first pitch comes from chase howard tell
us who's scoring a touchdown today
all right we got all our players right
here let's see which one hits
mike evans
mike evans coming in on the spin the
bottle legend and we got decision time
it is the first match-up of the day
coming from cameron grant let's see the
pick
[Music]
the treat legend going with naji harris
but greg we're going to call that the
demon legend because that is a cat my
friend we got mike evans at plus money
we got naji harris minus money but he's
a beast we know what it is how you
feeling about these how are the people
feeling about these what do we need from
them
let me talk to the people first conor
what i need you guys to do is get in the
comments and tell me which one are we
right are we riding with mike evans in
this bottle spin legend or are we going
with the treat legend conor calls it the
demon legend and naji hair we no we know
what naji is in pittsburgh he is the
workhorse there in pittsburgh
but connor you know what i like i like
value i like plus money and my guy mike
evans has been balling he's actually
scored in the last four weeks tom brady
has been feeding him in the red zone he
is a big red zone target for tom brady
he's sitting that plus money i think i
want to lean that way which way are you
riding i like it greg you're all over it
since the antonio brown injury mike
evans has been a monster in the end zone
tom brady is feeding this guy mike evans
has got it done year after year since he
came into the league love naji harris
there's no doubt about that the thing
that always worries me with the steelers
is they played in a lot of gritty low
scoring games where you know najib might
catch eight passes here or there run the
ball a million times there's no
guarantee for points all the time so for
mike evans that plus money is kind of
what seals the deal here where are the
comments going with our first match up
here
connor the comments is all over mike
evans they're all over mike evans i got
d marv for mvp says evan lock and he has
an emoji uh i got
isaac boatman saying bottle spinners i
got my boy larry hall of fame larry is
in the building uh oh his comment went
away he said harris is easy money it's
back and forth in the comments conor is
back and forth from the comments but
guess what you know what
i'm gonna make a decision
i'm gonna make a decision my boy matt
dodger has just
he just verified it he just verified it
we are riding with mike evans in the
bottle spin legend to move on to the
next round also also connor
if i said your name you're walking away
with a hoodie i just want you guys to
know that pretty good deal first round
belongs to the bottle spin chase howard
we got two challengers remaining let's
go on to round two let's keep this thing
moving the next pitch comes from jake
the snake let's see the choice
all right we got the mike evan lobster
the jalen hurts wine bottle
and the ultimate selector
i will
who's doing it for us this week
oh it's jaylen
good girl
the merlot legend the good girl picking
jalen hurts who's looking to feast on
that new york giants team today we got
double plus money here greg we got mike
evans plus 105. we got jalen hurts who's
been a fantasy monster these last couple
weeks at plus 120 i think you can get
that sky high
what do we got going on with this one
how are we feeling is this enough to
knock off mike evans that's a juicy pick
yeah it's juicy what i need everybody in
the comments to do is let me know let me
know are we rocking with mike evans are
we walking with jalen hurts i see
winter's only is in the comments winters
only is in the comments uh winners only
gang is in the comments conor uh i see
uh y'all let me know which one we rock
away uh
i'm kind of torn here connor i'll be
honest i'm kind of torn i just went over
why i like mike evans he's a red zone
target brady loves fighting him scored
in the last four weeks
but uh my guy jalen hurts he had a good
game last week connor i don't know if
you noticed my guy got in the end zone
rushing three times last week i do see
that uh continuing that trend when they
get in the five
you know closer to the to the go to the
goal line
the jalen hurts package the jalen hurts
power right power left
i think that that's going to come out so
uh
i'm rocking with jalen hurts i like
jalen hurts where do you rocket with
hunter yeah i like it too i think that
plus 120 is where i'm sitting at the
eagles have finally built an offense to
their quarterback strengths and jalen
hurts where they know he doesn't have to
go out there and throw 250 300 350 yards
every week but he could add on 70. he
can get he could be your red zone
offense like you said greg you're within
the 10 once you're within the five use
his mobility to get in the end zone he's
a key threat as a touchdown scorer with
his legs and the eagles are relying on
that for points right now they are not
relying on their running backs as much
as most teams because of what he can do
i love the mike evans pick i wouldn't be
mad if that one moves forward but with
jalen hurts it's hard to bet against him
right now more importantly it's hard to
expect anything out of the new york
giants to stop him
where are the comments gonna take it for
round three
connor i'm in the comments man and they
got me over here smiling
winter's only's in the building connor i
don't know if you know but winners only
is in the building uh jj snell j.j snell
says hertz is the guy they only run the
ball and they have no running backs
shout out to you jj snow you're walking
away with a hoodie i got wooden doors
says mike evans two touchdowns connor
it's a lock he's pulling the old connor
rogers playbook with the two touchdown
uh score
uh
he's getting he's that's a ball bet but
we're going to get to beau bets in a
minute i got uh z siegel says hertz is
the loch ness monster shout out to
lockheed town shout out to my boy mikey
glocks i got one more connor one more uh
dacking games decking gams says hurts so
therefore connor it's done therefore
your boy jalen hurts is moving on to the
next round that's right oh yeah by the
way
everybody i mentioned sorry connor but
everybody i mentioned you're walking
away with a hoodie all right the merlot
legend jake the snake takes round two
that is jalen hurts at plus 120 he has
one more matchup until maybe just maybe
we got a squad ride leader so final
contender winner takes all a familiar
face in and goldberg to close this thing
out
what's up bleacher report with it being
the first night of hanukkah we're gonna
use our trusty dreidel here to determine
this week's anytime touchdown score here
we go
if it lands on
shin we're picking jonathan taylor if it
lands on gimmel we're picking corio
patterson if it lands on none we're
picking cup and if it lands on hay we're
picking jacoby myers
and it landed on shin for picking
jonathan taylor this means anytime
touchdown score
all right jt at -200 a happy hanukkah
for all those that celebrate the
hanukkah legend and goldberg coming in
the clutch here
greg
you know what this comes down to do you
want to be bold or do you want to go
with old faithful jt
scores every week but minus 200 yeah not
really that exciting to be honest with
you but you like a safe bet who doesn't
jalen hurts plus 120. we don't pick plus
money on this show a lot and you find a
way to get it there i want to see what
you could do with this one let's close
this thing out how you feeling
ah connor before i give my take i want
everybody in the comments to let me know
how they are filling what they want to
ride with are we riding with jonathan
taylor are we going with
jalen hurts
but uh i don't know connor minus 200
that is a lot of juice we know my guy
jonathan taylor scored in the last eight
weeks we know he's an mvp candidate we
know
that he is the engine of that colts
d offense offense he's the engine of
that coach offense
but jalen hurts is sitting that plus
120. connor you know how i value my plus
money uh i think i might want to lean
that way which way are you lean which
way are you feeling i'm gonna go bold
here right i mean it just comes down to
it jt's been so good that he's starting
to play his way out of this once you get
into the minus 200 range there's only so
much you could do with those odds jalen
hurts is undoubtedly riskier there's no
doubt about that you're betting on a
quarterback to score but he's the dude
that can do it plus 120. let's get that
thing boosted up can we sway the comment
section to ride with us again we've done
it every week and honestly the hit rate
on the squad ride right now is
phenomenal let's do it one more time
let's see if we can do it i'm in the
comments i am in the comments
i got jt for mvp 0 says taylor lock of
the week
yeah it's minus 200 brother
i think it was a lock uh
there we go we got uh backwood herbie
says hertz for the come up plus 120 why
not shout out to you backwood uh here we
go i got
bad sports take says i think jonathan
taylor will pop off this week i mean
he's been popping off every week good
sport good take right there uh shimmy
burger jt is a lot coming off a 5t game
no way he scores uh no way he doesn't
scores jt is a lock why not two for jt
shout out to use chimney burger hey uh
you know what i got maxwell rexella in
the comments going with hurts
it's back and forth connor um the next
one i say we're just gonna ride with
down with that one let's do it down with
that
all right here we go uh i got
em go blue thank you thank you for for
the for the vibes i got him go blue with
the vibes
uh
wow they're they're moving
hey albert
albert albert all right here we go
albert 15 says hurts against the giants
he's getting two teddies shout out to
you albert15 you were walking away with
hoodie and connor
we made a decision it's a wrap we've
come to a conclusion
it is a rap fonito
we are riding with jalen hurts
and the murlett legend
is winning but jalen hurts we're riding
with you two score a touchdown today
let's pull up the graphics so i can show
you guys what we do here uh you guys see
that it's plus 120 poof there it is
thanks to our friends at draftkings
we are boosting that from plus 120 to
plus 200 check be our betting social for
links to the odds we'll send us your
screenshots of your bets send us your
videos and your celebrations but we want
winners only
please
plus 200 that is the best we've seen so
far let's get it done today jalen hurts
and speaking of done we are not done we
got more hoodies we got more locks greg
has still got a jersey gift card to give
away so if you're not the squad ride
leader you've still got a chance
community comment contest time right
after that crazy performance last week
from jt where he basically lived in the
end zone his mvp odds have moved up to
plus 1600. now let's not forget a
running back has not won mvp since
adrian peterson in 2012 so it's been a
while this has become a quarterback
award and that's why he's down at the
bottom there and all the guys ahead of
him are quarterbacks so you got the odds
board this week we asked you in the br
betting community stream if taylor
should win the mvp we picked our
favorite two comments to see what you
think greg what'd we get from the
comment section on jt
i need you guys i need you guys to get
in the comments and tell me which of
these is the better take i'm giving out
a hoodie to whoever you choose let's
take a look at the first comment from
domo
dell dumbo dell says if this happens the
nfl better be ready for major backlash
y'all ignored henry 2k season he didn't
get a single mvp vote last year that is
very very very interesting
connor
what is your take on that
dom i feel you but shouldn't we be
pushing for better you're not wrong but
if the voters finally get this thing
right and start giving more love to
non-quarterbacks that's a good step in
the right direction so yeah henry
kind of got jobbed a little bit right
he's greatness does not get appreciated
but jt if it starts to get appreciated
more for this colts team that doesn't
get a ton out of carson wentz then great
so be it i understand
the disappointment there but i think
jonathan taylor getting mvp love is a
really good thing for this award
i dudes i agree i agree with that connor
now let's move on to the next comment
from mike sam
eight
three shout out to mike sam a3 he said
he should be that five td game was
impressive yes it was very very very
impressive
conor what is your take on my guy mike
sam's
take right here i love it jonathan
taylor should be getting more credit
right everybody's so afraid of one of
these quarterbacks running away with it
that those odds are still down to plus
1600 essentially a laugher at that point
right everybody's a little afraid of you
know tom brady uh getting one before he
finally rides off and god knows when
kyler murray coming back healthy we know
what he can do so i love this comment
good vibes all around and really good
vibes around one of the best young
offensive players in the entire league
and jonathan taylor
yes yes yes let me hop into these
comments connor let me hop into these
comments
and see what they're talking about my
guy justin baldfield is spamming us
please do not spam us justin i will give
you a hoodie for good takes uh here we
go we got app steal uh app still says jt
is literally the goat he has every
running back record right now yards tds
total yards over
cooper cup who you all think is the goat
shout out to you ab still for your take
um you were in the comments
giving us good takes i got
isaac boatman isaac boatman says jt 150
all-purpose yards and two touchdowns
today shout out to you isaac boatman
locks underwater lots underwater says
matthew stafford
he likes matthew stafford he's broken
right now
he's got elbow problems he's got back
problems
i'm not trailing that one sorry greg
yeah i mean
yeah you're out
i'm just gonna i i agree there and
they're in the division as the niners
and i mean you see what we did to them a
couple weeks ago anyway uh
i'm just make a decision here i think i
want to go with dom odell i'm gonna go
with dom odell dumbledore's take the
first one was was it was good it was
good and uh you are walking away with a
hoodie
all right don model grabbing that hoodie
we are not done yet we are not even on
the boldest bets yet we're talking
player props it's time for prop lock or
drop it all right let's get into it we
picked a couple player props that stuck
to app that stuck out to us in the slate
today and we need you of course we need
you the squad to help us with what we
got going on is it a lock or is it a
drop greg let the people know
that's right everybody i need you to get
in the comments and tell me if these
props are unlocked or if we need to drop
them e immediately i'm giving away
hoodies to whoever can help us out let's
check out the first one my guy jonathan
taylor tourette over or under 80 and a
half yards he had 32 carries for 185
last week
or no in week 11 uh scored five
touchdowns last week
can he continue the mvp caliber season
connor
what's your take of this do you think he
can do you think he can do it like
jt is he gonna is he gonna get 80 and a
half this is a trap bet greg because you
look at him go anything under 100 yards
for jt is a joke now it's not
all-purpose yards which he should be
fine in today he's going to catch the
ball a lot he's going to get his rushing
yards but that buck's defense is good
against the run they don't allow people
to go off against them single-handedly
todd bowles their defensive coordinator
is not afraid to sell out against the
run he's done it many times before they
have the front to do it they have the
speedy linebackers behind them to do it
i don't think jt gets shut down today
i'm not saying that he's going to get
his in the end zone he's going to get
his all-purpose yards i'm not on this
one i think he hovers between 60 to 75
rushing yards i i think the bucks
defense uh is way too good i really
think this is a trap bet what do you
think
connor i mean let me see what the people
think because
i think
i see a lot of ogres my boy w trammell
says over 85
80 and a half lock it in uh i got
see justin see see when you justin
bonfield when you give us a good take
like how you did you get a hoodie he
said over greg but don't hate the spam i
just get no love been following connor
since the stf days old school appreciate
it
much love trying to get your attention
love to take justin
uh here we go
actually that's it connor that that
that's it if you if you guys are looking
in the comments which everybody that's
in the brf is they see justin taylor is
flooding the comments the over
everybody's saying the over let's move
on to our next prop
mac jones the guy
for new england uh mack jones to throw
over under 20 230 and a half yards he
has been performing huge for the
patriots
however only threw for 207
and a touchdown last week can he pick it
up this week and lead the patriots to
victory over the titans connor do you
like
max jones throwing over
230 and a half yards today greg i just
don't know if they'll let him quite
frankly that's what it comes down to i
think new england's gonna ride today i
think they covered the line that opened
up at six and a half tennessee's just
got so many injuries they got all their
wide receivers on the ir they're beat up
across the board but new england's
running backs are both going to play it
sounds like and damien harris and ramon
jay andre stevenson
mac's been super efficient he's done
everything they've asked of him i think
that he'll have a really good day
through the air but that doesn't mean
he'll be allowed to just throw the ball
40 times so 230 is not a big number but
it wouldn't shock me again if mack is
hovering around 210 215 and new england
gets a good lead early sits on the ball
and just goes run run run they dominate
in the trenches uh this is another prop
bet greg that i think is a trap maybe
i'm wrong people love to root for overs
and that's how they get you i'm a guy
that'll root for nothing to happen and
go with the unders
no i like that i like that connor and
not only do i like that
the people in the comments are agreeing
with you i see a lot of unders uh c4 shs
under 230 the patriots are going to run
it all day tennessee can't stop the run
there it is connor that that's that
sounds like connor to me uh wait hold on
hold on dj maury 10 says over for the
mac attack the titans have a better run
defense than pass defense i don't know
if that's valid uh
but just just because of the take we're
gonna send him a hoodie uh one more
carter one more
ram tackle says mac jones rookie of the
year 265 yards today with three
touchdowns best rookie in the class best
coach in the history of sports
you're walking away with a hoodie um i
think my guy hasn't watched jamar chase
this year but we'll keep it moving
love the takes yeah the takes are good
all right the takes are good may the
betting gods be in our favor on the
props all right before we get out of
here greg this is where you and i get to
have some fun it's time for boldest pets
you've been scorching hot on these so
let's keep those good vibes going let
the people what know what we need before
we drop our bets
get in the comments and give us a bow
bet we we want a long shot we want that
plus plus plus plus money um also tell
us whether you're riding with me or
connor connor
give it to the people tell them what you
got yeah if anyone's riding with me
today they're insane because this is my
this is my biggest hail mary of the year
right now plus
1504 michael carter put on ir for the
jets that means it's tied johnson's show
in that backfield against the houston
texans kyle pitts i know the atlanta
offense has struggled but kyle pitts
against the jaguars he's going to be
atlanta's offense today especially with
a banged up quarter l patterson and then
debo samuel your boy greg he is a
monster running the ball catching the
ball he's obviously the guy you feel the
most good about on this list where are
you going this week on our boldest bets
[Music]
connor let's pull up the graphic let's
pull up the graphic let's just i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna get straight to it
let's pull up the graphic there it is
tom brady to throw basically 300 yards
and my boy jonathan taylor have the over
rushing uh yards you see there i i i see
this game uh being a good one i see this
game being a good one but i think both
offenses will kind of get in the flow
and uh there it is hopefully this is
number three in a row we hit two of them
in a row and hopefully this one uh will
continue shout out to my boy matt dodger
by the way shout out to matt dodger he's
a legend greg looking for the hat trick
this week on boldest bets that would be
a first time on the squad ride i'm
feeling it all right we need the people
to pick who they're riding with and you
got to get rid rid of that nfl jersey
gift card before we sign off for week
number 12.
yes sir i got jessie 24 get greg
verified yeah
let's do it if that happened bleacher
report gotta make that happen here we go
uh but that that that deserves a uh
uh a jersey for me you're getting a
jersey jesse cause that that's that's a
fact uh here we go gotta give away some
more hoodies uh
i see
go garden says both of us
shout out to you go garden um
backwood her herbie is back he said both
of us have great bets okay here we go
colin corey 20 says devonta adams have
two touchdowns and a hundred yard shout
out to you colin cory you're walking
away with a hoodie uh
cody jarvis says great bet
to both of us all right
and yeah i mean they're saying conor's
the guy greg's the guy
greg for mvp connor never lets us down
mo dz shout out to you cleo shout out to
you dboy22 shout out to you and that's
it connor that's a wrap and everybody i
said getting hoodies hey
yeah exactly connor finished it for me
[Laughter]
pretty good pretty good all right good
luck with your wagers everyone congrats
to all our hoodie there was many many
hoodie winners and the two jersey
winners br benning will dm you within
the next 24 hours thanks to everyone
that commented thank you to the lock
legends that sent videos keep those
videos coming chase howard cameron grant
jake the snake and goldberg the hanukkah
legend we got a lot of good videos this
week enjoy your football sunday
everybody drop your real time takes in
the sports betting community stream in
that bleacher report app where you're
watching us right now follow us once
connor cutter countercutting
i'm sorry brother i'm sorry i'm
considering you i was just going to let
you keep staying around i was i promised
you i was going to let you keep going
but i saw something about cam newton
here we go ayo rob fusic says greg is
solid get cam to have three or more
total touchdowns
i like that my boy cam newton superman
cam and he was doing a lot of yelling
last week i don't i mean they ended up
losing so he was like yelling for no
reason but i like the energy i like the
energy superman camp getting the enzo
and shout out to ayo rob man thanks for
sticking around cause you just want to
hit you know the deal you stick around
you might just walk away with the hoodie
alongside greg ivory i'm connor rogers
see you next week same time same place
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign